four people were killed in an ambush
style shooting overnight at a party in
California investigators say ten people
were shot in a neighborhood in Fresno a
little more than three hours north of
Los Angeles six were wounded Jonathan
Vigliotti has the latest on the
investigation Jonathan what do we know
right now
interracial good morning at least 35
people were gathered in the backyard of
a home to watch football at some point
the group was ambushed by gunfire and
this party of family and friends turned
into a scene of chaos and confusion in
all ten people were shot when police say
a suspect or suspects snuck into the
backyard of the home and opened fire
four people were killed six victims were
taken to the hospital but expected to be
okay detectives went door-to-door
overnight searching for witnesses and
possible security camera footage police
say at this time there is no indication
the victims knew the suspect or suspects
all ten victims were Asian males between
25 and 35 years old police say there
were several women and children at this
party none of them were injured federal
agents from San Francisco are now
assisting in the investigation and
police have not said at this point what
type of weapon was used in the attack a
motive is also unclear as a precaution
police have increased patrols in the
area this morning Tony and we'll stay on
it Jonathan thank you very much